welcome to this video playing against
love from France yeah
so let's hope this game will be somewhat
better than the to warm up games that I
played and lost terribly this the kind
of games that always make me a bit angry
against those type of players who just
instantly bash out moves
and yeah we always feel like what is
playing this so quickly how I suppose
how can he possibly do that and so they
can all right this is a strange one with
c5 man this is I took it and tried to
keep the pawn it looks a bit artificial
but still it's an important pawn
let's see you should I go Queen a phone
to to make sure to keep it maybe you
know he can maybe capture on play Knight
a six trying to keep the pawn I'm sorry
trying to get it back when I just got
Knight e4 Knight g4 also after the trade
yeah probably this wasn't such a great
idea
it just feels some like him lacking some
harmony in my position okay so he
probably yeah still night you form
[Music]
hmm yeah this is really ugly Chesham
okay I'm still doing it
I'd like to prevent the Knighton's to
afford reform possibly and get the place
for this bishop on f2
[Music]
yeah very interesting at least I'm not
behind on the clock he can try this
tactical shots like Knight e4 Knight g4
here but I can take a five this should
just win material after Knight g4 I
cannot take the night because of Bishop
c3 but um still I can first take on a5
okay so I'm pretty I'm pretty good in
terms of keeping the pawn but still yes
compensation rook see one would return
the part of me at least so I wonder do I
really need to move the King here very
ugly yeah I need to keep it I mean if I
return the pawn how good can my position
beam yeah that exactly that's exactly
the problem opening it up further but
take here route d6 is coming still not
much choice okay well here there's
Bishop c5
tonight is six Bishop III try to keep
the position closed and if for ya this
is the kind of tight don't try this at
home game sometimes everyone everyone
can be good he agreed and that was
greedy yet yeah good good ending night
66 my development is just terrible hmm
before night takes and the king yeah but
he can open it up with f5 and yeah not
much choice I came a Knight takes e4 is
a big threat yeah I don't know where the
the king is some safest relatively
speaking maybe back here you know we
still has a huge initiative
[Music]
I know the bishops but at least I'm
speeding up my development a bit I mean
okay the bishops are just start with the
problem the the light squares is the
real the real deal
now you can take on c3 and on c5 to get
the pawn back but this should at least
should show check yes but this this
keeps I thank me out of immediate danger
if I get and get this exchange now check
yeah yeah okay this should be a should
be okay for for white
[Music]
okay Brooke d1 and King III something
like that should be okay to to equalize
[Music]
intending 95 and possibly be formed no I
can go before now this this was a
blunder taking on b5 with the check and
winning upon check check
[Music]
so I wanna pawn is it enough to win the
game though ok now I can take and player
4 this should be excellent getting
getting to d4 and I have 91 to e3 yes or
even d5 yeah I'm getting it for as well
that's the important thing
whoo yeah it probably wasn't trouble I
mean this was far too greedy
in the opening black resigned frankly
speaking a very artificial play from my
side yeah I don't know c5 is quite
strange here and this exact position but
okay maybe you can play that and the
just transpose to Benoni I tried to
refute it somehow and probably this
isn't such a great idea I mean maybe it
is playable but it's certainly nothing
nothing great I mean what he did was
fine to get good compensation yeah and
here black must be fine brilliant yeah
computer gives like a substantial
advantage
just like he played
and here it's a matter of precision
which is often the problem and let's see
you know that you you have a good
position but you don't find the right
moves this is very similar to the the
the gambit in this image but put c5t I'm
even worse in terms of coordination yeah
it was everything else was excellent
yeah I think this is just this is too a
little bit too materialistic but it it
just helps me to coordinate exchanging
this monster bishop against this a
four-night he wanted to probably clarify
the situation but it's probably good to
just let me make a move here it's not
easy he can maybe just improve further
yeah after this I think it should be
quote really and the worst is definitely
over here yeah we are we just talking
about an equal position yeah but this is
just blunders blunders I guess the game
away I don't really think that this is
that you can save that yeah why does
winning here there's no reason why it
shouldn't it's it's a pass on the bee
farm and there are some weaknesses in
black structure not huge ones but think
that white white can exploit so this was
a bit lucky this is not really advisable
what entity I'm trying to hang on to the
porn in this way alright thanks for
watching